well you know part is just a perfect
place for murder
[Applause]
[Music]
overdue Doctor Who review we keep moving
along and before we get into the latest
one that I'm gonna talk about I say
latest when these things are old as heck
now I'm old ah my mortality staring me
in the face but before we fall down that
existential rabbit hole let's just point
out that this particular video is
brought to you by radio versus the
Martians it is a podcast that talks
about all manner of geeky things as the
McLaughlin group for nerds Mike Gillis
Casey Dorn and a revolving number of
guests
they come in they talk about all sorts
of stuff superhero movies comic books
wrestling Arnold Schwarzenegger films
when they do that it's really kind of
amazing and it is always fun it's always
funny sometimes even a little insightful
radio versus the Martians calm or
wherever you get your podcast so we are
now up to the unicorn and the wasp and
this one is kind of a funny one because
on paper there's a lot for me to take
issue with and even off paper there's a
lot that I do actually take wishy issue
wish you god I can speak issue with but
ultimately I still kind of enjoyed this
and I think it's a little bit like robot
of Sherwood for me in that the
performances and the chemistry and the
banter between the leads is what
elevates it above the actual story
because the actual story is kind of like
mmm and this is also one of those times
where I feel like Doctor Who was a
little too self-aware I'll get to that
though so we've got the doctor and Donna
in the 1920s at a party which of course
has Donna all excited which I love that
I love I love
he was the thing like she gets really
pumped up for this party but back to
backing these the way that I am for this
rewatch she gets so excited everywhere
she goes
ghosts ancient Rome super excited ghosts
run out of the planet super excited goes
1920s super excited I love how thrilled
she is everywhere she ends up it's oh
god I love Donna so much so we've got
1920s so we've got lovely uh you know
stiff upper lip British folk and a nice
posh party and Agatha Christie played uh
very well by uh an actress who I should
have looked up and whose name I will now
put at the bottom of the screen so that
I don't have to stop what I'm doing and
go grab my phone and check it and then
edit it cuz I don't like to edit cuz I'm
lazy hi this all reflects really badly
on me anyways she's quite good she has a
great rapport with both the doctor and
Donna which is kind of essential I mean
like any good guest appearance needs a
solid rapport with both the doctor and
the companion ideally at the very least
with the doctor and she absolutely has
that plus I like sort of the recreation
of an Agatha Christie setting we've got
our list of suspects we have an isolated
location we've got you know nobody's got
a decent alibi and I like I like all
that and the thing is I think it is just
the camera and like I'm part of it might
also be I'm partial to a good mystery
anyways although it's debatable how good
a mystery this actually is on the merits
of a good mystery story but I'm kind of
a sucker for the time period I'm kind of
a sucker for the general vibe of an
Agatha Christie style mystery so it gets
me to overlook stuff that otherwise
bothers me so and also like I said the
episode was too self-aware in some areas
it is but in others like it's just
self-aware enough which is that not only
does it kind of point out and hang a
lampshade on the whole wait a minute
we're solving a murder mystery with
Agatha Christie what are the odds of
this you know they do kind of have a
lampshade hanging joke with Donna going
oh you know that's like having Dickens
that Christmas with ghosts and you know
they kind of pointed that out back in
the unquiet dead as well I'm pretty sure
but what the extra bit that they have
here that cell
for me is they have the whole thing with
the vespiform sort of coming to a
knowledge of itself and what it is
activating the fire stone and because
his mother was reading an Agatha
Christie Agatha Christie novel at that
time and that was what was in her mind
at the same time he got his history as
an alien species dumped into his head he
also got act the Christie dumped into
his head so he thinks that's how society
and the world functions so it actually
gives a reason why this insanely
contrived one of the friggin odds thing
is kind of happening and while sometimes
like there's a fine balance for that
sometimes it's not necessary to explain
why the ridiculous thing that's
happening is happening but there are
some times we're like I appreciate at
least a token acknowledgement that there
that there's a reason and in this case I
did appreciate that what I meant when I
said it might be a little too self-aware
it has to do with the way in which it
kind of unfolds so like we've got the
classic interrogating all the possible
suspects but it's things like the Wibbly
you know visual for for when we go into
the flashbacks like that's that
self-aware in a way that just comes off
as being trying to be cute and it just
comes off what kind of like like a
Saturday morning cartoon kind of effect
like Oh flashback it's not necessary and
they like layer it cuz they have like
the one Ds what he's here colonel he
like rude to a flashback of him being
you know in the library reminiscing and
then within the flashback woooo do you
know what it is he's thinking about it
like this it's just stop stop it makes
it all just slightly too goofy which
again it is kind of a goofy idea but
like somebody's dead it's a murder
mystery I kinda wish it was taken a
little bit more seriously in terms of
the overall tone of the thing I'm also
complained in the past about the best
perform about the fact that it's just a
giant wasp and I still don't like that
you know the way that the whole thing
pans out with you know why it is in
terms of its father and the vicar being
you know being this unknowing secret son
and all that like all that's fine and
even you know the fact that this person
who theoretically should have retained
some empathy towards humanity because
you've still raised as human even when
he got all the stumped up dumped in his
head like suddenly turns and like he's
ready to kill whoever I'm even kind of
willing to go with that but giant wasp
like ultimately what I don't like about
that is it's just lazy it's the same
issue I have with the cat nuns it's just
taking something that we already have on
earth and making it bigger or making it
humanoid like oh it's so alien like well
no it's a wasp it's big but it's a wasp
and that kind of takes the well it it
takes the imagination on it because
there's no imagination that goes into it
and it also like it like I know I know
cuz last time I complain about this a
million people wanted this out to me and
I guess I didn't make this point clear
enough I know that a wasp is used in one
angat the Christie story the show itself
points that out but it's not like wasps
were a big recurring theme with her they
were used in one story in a notable
fashion it's not even one of her
best-known stories so that to me felt
like a really weak justification I feel
like they decided that the killer was
gonna be a giant some kind of animal and
they would just like scoured through as
the Christie books um what one has an
animal play an important part oh there's
a wasp in this pool giant wasps so again
it feels lazy and even though they find
a way to connected to Agatha Christie
that connection is so flimsy to me it
doesn't justify the fact that this is
still just lazy and it just is I'm sorry
so like
that irritates me again the way the best
perform is used and it's narrative
function in the story all of that I'm
cool with I'm fine with all that it's
just the fact that it's a big wasp don't
like it but again I do actually enjoy
this episode because it is saved by the
performances I really love and it's
funny because as much as I didn't like
the excuse me the pantomime gag in
partners in crime I do actually kind of
like the charades thing that goes on
here with the doctor and Donna I think
it's because like the doctor getting to
vent his frustration or one word like
that the way that it escalates I think
is what makes this scene work as opposed
of the pantomime thing which just kind
of keeps doing the same thing for like a
minute this feels like things are
escalating and there's an you know
there's a sense of danger and like we
gotta figure this out but we're
injecting a little humor into it so this
works better for me I'm and I do enjoy
that and as much as I don't like the
fact that Donna does kiss the doctor
like why did every companion up through
God declare kiss the doctor I feel like
she did at some point I feel like if I'm
wrong about that then at the very least
all the way through Amy the campaign
kisses the doctor at some point even if
like there's none of there's no romantic
feelings because with Donna there isn't
which is great but like I still wish you
didn't do it like it's did but again
it's a better reasoning than most of the
most of the time that we get least to my
taste and and what I prefer and I and I
really like Donna trying to you know get
into the mysteries like so if you didn't
kill him so she didn't kill him so she
did get and it's it's just it's just fun
the the banter the RET of the rapport
and and also like the supporting cast is
solid as well I mentioned The Vicar
already but honestly all of them are
pretty good and I like that I like first
of all that Donna corns on immediately
to the fact
that the the son of the the woman
hosting this party is gay
and like her only complaint is that you
know she doesn't get the hit on him not
really oh they're on the other bus well
you know all the good guys are on the
other bus or our actually that even if
it's it's implied that at the very least
the father of this gay character knows
and he he doesn't seem happy about it
but his frustration seems to be with a
lack of grandchildren to you know keep
the the title going which you know he
doesn't exude a lot of like genuine
anger at his son and considering the way
that could have been played I mean it's
not it's not tolerance I'm not going to
claim that what we see is tolerance from
him which would have been weird given
the time but you know considering how
heavy-handed it could have been pretty
well handled he does get killed off so
it might get filed under barrier queers
but you know that's a that's a whole
other thing but yeah in any case and
then I'll wrap it up there like there's
a lot of weird issues with this thing
that I have but ultimately I do still
enjoy watching it
so it's an episode that is fun in spite
of itself if I think the main thing is
if they hadn't gotten as good a cast for
you know the guest cast for this and in
if it wasn't Donna if it was like I do
honestly any of the other companions
this that this might be painful for me
but they managed to get some elements
that work really well enough to sort of
overcome a fair amount of stuff that I
don't really care for but we'll wrap it
up there so unicorn and the wasp you
seen it what do you think about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it there's a whole bunch of
stuff down there as well cuz there's
buttons and links
there's the like button kind of
important these days it would seem plus
you know you can subscribe and the P
John keeps me going and keeps this
channel improving plus rewards for that
there's merch and there's my social
media stuff and all sorts of things
click on them like the links they take
you places but you don't have to because
at the end of the day folks
you're the council I'm just running the
meetings in until next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]